[Music]
in 2019 teachers struck in Denver Los
Angeles Chicago in response district
officials mostly caved to the Union wish
list even when the concessions didn't
make a lot of sense
for students or taxpayers they caved
because they didn't want to be seen as
anti teacher wanted teachers back in
schools quickly and found it easy to
make concessions for which the bill will
only come due on the next guys watch yet
it's possible to do better back in 2011
Wisconsin made it harder for district
leaders to give away the store the
Legislature passed act 10 which allowed
unions to negotiate over wages like they
always had but stopped the strong arming
of districts on things like school
schedules in health care the result an
extra billion dollars a year for
classrooms due mostly to pension reforms
and competitively priced health care
plans it's important to both pay
teachers better and ensure that public
funds are spent responsibly Wisconsin
offers one model for how to make that
happen do you think teacher unions
should be able to bargain on things like
school schedules in health care let us
know in our poll also let us know what
other topics you'd like our scholars to
cover in 60 seconds and be sure to LIKE
and subscribe for more research and
videos from AEI